wait i got a question if you bulay kev
where is like um official version i
don't know
uh
i've never wondered that yeah
i used to sell fake [ __ ] this pirated
kid i was pirating a lot of stuff when i
was in high school
anyway welcome to the uh show the bullet
cab show special guest stunner man 02.
how y'all doing yeah you look good why
the o2 uh stunner man from the pack you
know i'm saying also you know o2 is the
chemical symbol for oxygen gas that's
all i spit oh i'm saying
you spit that gas i mean you know i'm
not gonna brag too much just trying to
be myself wait you were in the pack no
no no no that's how i got to say bro i
remember you all like wait wait i don't
remember seeing you buddy
[Laughter]
i looked up to him a lot and then in my
hood little uno's from was uh from the
same hood i was living in honduras
i'm saying so we see all them around you
know vance came out bt it's the biggest
thing out i'm dark skinned with waves
they everybody called me stunning so you
know i ended up meeting them we had a
slight uh interaction and from there you
know it turned into respect i ended up
seeing him two three years ago and he
for me when you say slight interaction
what does that mean like you guys had
some static yeah i was a little kid and
i was like i was short struck and i was
like there you go stunning man from the
pack and i was held to juice and he kind
of like brushed me off i said it to him
like four times and then he was like he
kind of was a little rude about it and
then i was just like feminine i just
kind of buffed up because i'm like man i
like you you know i mean why are you not
giving me that feedback and i had
already met a couple people from the
pack or one another person from the pack
and that kind of brushed me off too so i
was wearing that and it's like see say
you meet a hero at the time of your life
and they don't give you that love you
know i mean so you're not kind of buffed
up that's happened to me before exactly
we cool now though shout out to him who
was it oh the first time i met philly
phil he was a weirdo peru yeah yeah that
just met philly that's hella funny he's
cool now yeah he's hella cool now we're
both heavy hitters and yeah okay before
i was like a thing you know before i was
just some kid in phoenix i was like yo
fellaini phil what's up man he just yeah
you didn't try to use something he's
done a man me no i don't give i away
stun a man nah he he keith is hella cool
he does art now you feel me we talk you
know i mean he's like man go wear that
stunning man name now i'm looking for
stunning man oh three so femi if
stunning man 03 is out there coming to
get you
hey shout out to the heavy hitters man
they show me love in dallas oh i heard
you were out there um uh i heard you
stole the show at the at the thing i was
supposed to go but i just i wouldn't say
that they put it in my hands and i just
made sure security well i heard you had
that [ __ ] i heard you were like
the highlight of the oh thank you you
know i'm saying i look like i guess i'm
like women's makeup there you know what
i'm saying yeah
the highlight of ours oh by the way nico
blitz is here who you
you guys competed against each other in
high school yeah or something what
happened with y'all's relationship now
isn't it oh real quick shout out all the
dj's out there i had a different uh
level of appreciation for djs after i
went to heavy hitters for sure i learned
a lot of history yeah but alright me and
me even the twitch djs yeah exactly yep
he slided you right there
i heard it i heard your song first
because i thought every time i hear your
song i just pictured nico doing his this
face and [ __ ] so yeah when i was in high
school i used to uh horrible
i used to date filipino women and nico
actually stole my girl yeah you know his
girl yeah i assure you you have the
bigger dick
it's medium nico's a four he's he's a
four banger yeah okay and he's proud
listen five five if you're really happy
well it makes sense why she came back
yeah there we go wait is this real you
guys really had a little chicken no no
no no
no no no no [ __ ] ain't stealing
nobody's [ __ ] let's be honest
we were we weren't a couple could tell
you it was like
it's like when a filipino woman turns
18. they like celebrate her life
so it's like a killer
yeah filipino heritage hey say it again
debut there we go so it's a filipino
ended up getting hella drunk we just
practiced hell and much we did hip-hop
you know a lot of filipinos could dance
you know nico when he was rapping he was
rapping oh yeah yeah peru's in high
school bro for real yeah
cook you got the remote over there play
that i need you to pull that sure thing
video up come on on the tv oh wow
big mcgill
[Music]
san francisco state
hey
rarity is that your high school niko
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
month right here
this is history
i can't believe we're doing this how
much did you weigh there niko uh buck 20
roughly
you feel me are you a big step
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he went backwards up the stairs
all
there's an acoustic version of that as
well i need to hear that there literally
is there's some guy playing guitar and
nico's for that was at skyline college
oh okay yeah yeah i'm gonna put out
hey it's filipino american history month
yeah shout out
we need to get a uh
a blowhorn for every time we say it's a
heritage or history
okay well anyway
uh so
now we know how you got your name yep
yeah shout out to stunner man
i mean shout out to o2 guys you know
it's crazy i always say this like i
think the loki like uh
what what happened in l.a with like
mustard and all that whole sound that
came out of l.a i feel like it started
with the pack man for sure it started
with a lot of people pack diligence um
yeah that's a whole bunch of people even
larry jones rapping back then larry
jones sound was completely different i
mean i feel like pila was talking about
the other day there's no slight to
nobody else but debate would just be i'm
not going to say ahead we'll just be in
a different space than a lot of people
you guys are in your own like
it's like your own thing yeah and it's
not like and it's just like when people
catch wind of it when you're doing it a
lot of times when you're innovating it
don't hit as as hard as somebody
imitating for example like when android
was making these touch screen phones we
wasn't on it but as soon as apple came
with it it was the best thing ever i
mean facts so i'm saying exactly you
know i happen to have a android i have
my iphone where's my little flip phone
yeah you need that what you be doing on
your free time you got a flip phone
uh it's a uh it's a it's the new i have
a galaxy uh house the flip joint okay we
know what he does in his free time no no
motorola you know what i'm saying
i really am missing my phone
yeah let's call it it's probably in my
car bro
oh well yeah no shots so are you android
guy no no i got an iphone um android
kudo you know i'm saying i ain't really
tripping if they was to pay me i would
definitely have one that's fair that's
fair yeah
so you know
so there's nothing that could get you
from an iphone to an android it's a lot
of things but right now outside of money
um like
i feel like uh the biggest thing
probably would be uh like the like this
social media translation because like
you know when you post stuff from an
android sometimes the quality is hella
bad you know there's a reason for that
yeah it's because
because i i tried to like i was an
android guy from yeah yeah yeah i mean i
got my iphone and i would never go back
yeah for sure you know why it's like
when people date my message for me it's
imessage and facetime and you know like
if i want to send someone something i
just text it to him yeah exactly if i
got an android about you you'll email
that they're like no i'm gonna text you
man no no you don't understand you can't
text me you got what you got whatsapp
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
what's up you gotta exchange it on
whatsapp no but what happens is uh all
those apps they make uh their apps for
iphones there's only a certain amount of
iphones right yeah so each app like
snapchat or or like ig you know how like
when you do your snapchats or your
stories it looks like [ __ ]
it's because
there's so many android models of phones
like thousands uh
it's a whole different yeah so
technically
because android or like snapchat can't
make like their app
compatible to a million androids it's a
mirror of the original video that
actually gets posted which is why it
looks like [ __ ] oh wow yeah that's
that's actually a cool concept when you
think about it for real
but apple is it's so uniform they can
just like yep come just copy and paste
man that's dope see that's why they win
it hey simplicity is key
i mean facts
yeah so um
how long have you been rapping uh i've
dropped my first single march 24th 2018.
uh i probably took a series five years
ago august 2016 made my first song 2009.
my boy spencer was telling me um yeah
that he uh he had met you uh when he was
working with cookies uh
how long ago i don't know it's probably
a few years ago oh yeah probably i did a
photo shoot with them like two years
that's what it was yeah my boy spence
used to run the uh hey rap to homie
streets you know what i'm saying he put
me on with that he was like yo stutter
man the young kid from the bay right i
was like yeah we did some stuff for the
for the cookies yeah
so um when did you kind of get your
first like
i guess
moment where you realized like you might
be able to kind of the first song i ever
dropped i pushed it all the way got to
the radio like with me i knew my stuff
was when i dropped something probably
like 43 people go listen to it so when i
did that when i was like gearing up
dropping stuff with people i knew if i
wanted to go somewhere it had to be
because i was pushing it i'm saying so
the first i was like i made a pact with
myself i was like the first song i drop
i'ma push this to the wheels fall off
like i made merch for it i was
performing everywhere i was like hosting
club events like throwing parties
everyday used to fight me not to perform
and i'd be like come on i'm performing i
don't care and now them same venues that
used to be like now you can't perform
i'm paying you paying me man that's
crazy how things come full circle don't
give up on your dreams [ __ ] what they
talking about believing you that's how
you gonna win there it is that's a
blessing bro yeah so you know i just
pushed it you know i mean i still push
that's why i've been doing a challenge
136 days i think it's 137 yeah i mean
what do you mean what's the big stepping
challenge you know i'm saying so
basically the big stepping right now i'm
going to say it's the hottest song on
the west coast come on look at it look
at
it
you know i'm saying i air dropped it to
nico before anybody else you filming me
but i've been pushing that 137 days and
it's like that just came from literally
every day having to push music because i
feel like people wasn't going to listen
you know what i'm saying so i was like
wait wait so
every day you're you're doing a new
every single day you're doing a tick
tock nah yeah tick tock instagram
twitter sometimes facebook mm-hmm
every single day 130
i've seen it yeah yeah i mean all the
although you got to get you to do it you
gonna hit it with us
wait show them show them the back of
your thing after you see me hey you feel
me man right there
i'm saying he goes girl hey there you go
nico's girl the young jackie yeah young
jim shout out to jackie did you tell her
about the girl that you stole from me
uh
i really i really wish that was true man
me too because i would want to fake i
would want to get a hold of this girl i
know i just see where her life is yeah
what happened like what did you see at n
bomb nico
jesus christ if you ever left me you're
probably not doing too well no well i
hope you're doing great though
i hope you're doing great well you did
like a uh it was a niners remix to the
record right yeah that [ __ ] was though
shout out to 49ers you know how'd that
happen obviously they're trash this year
but okay so my folks ace you know i mean
his cousin tapped in with us dj midnight
and then we did at first we was kind of
like we wasn't privy to it we was moving
to traffic we couldn't really sit down
for it then the 49ers reached out to
rich and my manager big rich and they're
like hey what's up man we want to get
stunning man on this if you don't do it
we're going to whoop your ass they
didn't really say that
but i was like do you want to do this
i'm like hell yeah that's my favorite
team you know i'm saying so it's like
once we did that locked it in as soon as
they told me it had to be done i went to
the studio right there locked in with
quake beats we knocked it out and then
finished up the official remiss the next
week was there like has a player hit
that [ __ ] on the piano yeah d-ball
samuel femme shout out to big kerr
number 92 he was the first player to hit
it in the game i mean on the niners yeah
he got a sack him saying he was hitting
that [ __ ] the niners they embraced it
yeah i mean i feel like you know maybe
because a season is not going how we
predict it you know have as much how is
that just so hey come on let's don't rub
it in here
don't rub it in no i don't you're a
raiders fan oh no i'm a cardinal i'm a
cardinals fan oh okay but how how's the
season going i haven't seen let's just
say um it's going equivalent to the
feeling that if you never won a super
bowl well that'd be me okay yeah i'm
saying i never won a super bowl
can we also say the warriors are four
and one right now hey they should have
won last night we should have no
49ers for me certain things they got to
get together and they organized this
yeah they got to file kyle shannon or
fire kyle shanahan because he is a
terrible head coach probably a solid
offensive coordinator for sure yeah but
yeah but man yeah yeah we're gonna we're
gonna get it together no tebow's the guy
though deebo go stupid
what's up bro beast man man go stupid
come pull up i got 19 reasons why you
should come big step with me
did you just offer him 19 thousand
dollars no okay
i'm like what are we talking about now
that's his number i know it's his number
but yeah there it is
no that i think that's no i mean
obviously like it's an easy thing to hit
if you score a touchdown it's like yeah
i should clean a shout out to our
millions of dollars
millions of dollars worth of games yeah
they put that in wallow and uh oh yeah
gilly it's their [ __ ] we should go today
podcast too
i'm actually supposed to be going to
philly to go for real i'm gonna go
i've never been to philly now you should
get that 100 cheesesteak
i'm good you're 100 cheesecake yeah you
you know that's like the inspiration for
why
from the book uh what was that book
called i don't remember
contagious i think that's what it's
called but yeah there was a 100
cheesesteak
sheesh that's what dipsy
we just share that 900
you're gonna love philly i just went to
dominican republic i locked in with a
cat from philly he was hella funny no i
know hella people from philly i only
drove through on a train no you got and
i was like yeah you know i was like they
don't love you out there i don't know if
they will not you won't know why because
you know philly is a the number one um
city for pirating in america so once you
say oh boulette kiev they're gonna be
like oh okay is that is that true i mean
is anything really true
i don't know
hey what up man we gotta interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for eye socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapateo underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview we all we sit in a suspended
ball of fire right now a sphere
listen hey but san francisco is the
number one smash and grab city correct
hey for real biffin is at a hall time
high i remember when like it became like
popularized god yeah so it's crazy it's
just crazy right now yeah i just seen it
develop it came from like a couple dudes
in the hood hidden to like literally
people hitting for over fifty thousand
dollars i remember when people i know
like they hit for like what was it gunna
like fifty a hundred thousand bruh
something crazy
just cash in the whip uh i think it was
a lot of game off camera yeah you know
what i'm saying i got hit i got hit last
year i [ __ ] left the bank someone
followed me and i ran into a ups store
and got [ __ ] they they hit me for
like 15 bands for real yeah
hey shout out to my block though because
they bit my window and i had like six
thousand dollars in there and a whole
bunch of other stuff and they didn't
take it i appreciate y'all i'll see what
the mayor is doing in san francisco
hundred thousand dollars hundred
thousand hey nico likes hey wait wait
just put nico out there
also
he need to go to jail and also [ __ ]
would not survive you never know he
might come back hella buff he gonna be
like yeah i got my bun braided
nick will be in jail running running
[ __ ]
you feel me i'll be with the asians
you see the mayor's also uh
they're paying people five hundred
dollars a piece to not shoot each other
oh that's dope i [ __ ] with that
in san francisco yeah san francisco one
of them cities where you don't if you're
not there you don't think this activity
happened but it's like no i go to san
francisco twice a month
and i always stay at the
intercontinental and i always see
someone overdosing on heroin outside big
drug city no there's like huge right
there they're just they don't care
they'll be like kids walking by with
their parents and some [ __ ]
just shooting up they offer you too you
get close enough
i think san francisco is a hell of a
food city though man
man you gotta go to uh hey sourdough
bread originated from san francisco
sourdough did sourdough bread oh no is
that just something that y'all want to
take credit for like everything else no
no no this is authentic yummy i just
gotta ask you yeah you know i mean you
got to take credit where it's due for
sure no i mean i give the bay a lot of
credit la i think a lot of la [ __ ] hell
yeah
tell me tell me the best sandwich spot
though oh they closed it down but it was
foot long sandwich spot on divisidero
but after that right now my top city
sandwiched by roxy's come on thank you
everybody nobody thank you and it's
[ __ ] up because they about to uh close
that down too hey [ __ ] gentrification
that's why we need to go back and buy
those properties after this uh boulet
kev actually told me that he's going to
start a foundation for a black san
francisco youth in order to uh uh
reverse nutrification in
san francisco let's go that's right
boulette kev
is the man
i'm sentimental too and i approve this
message
[Laughter]
well
what did i sign up for today
to be great
all right our lord and savior man hey
they need to uh give you like a brand uh
ambassador no you know what's crazy is
these [ __ ] i dm these [ __ ] because
they're this can is on this table i'm
i'm gonna stop
you know until they cut the check yeah
come on that was hella good though i'm
not gonna lie yeah these are fire man
crazy this is my crack for sure i need
one of these every day you should you
know when you go next time you go to san
francisco you see somebody shooting up
some heroin you should give him one of
those pop out nah you should pop one up
and just let me do it
i know how you feel now
you know i feel like heroin and crack
got to be fire though
what
here we go again no it has to be people
will leave their families for that which
means it has to be fired exactly yeah
it's got to be like the craziest feeling
ever if like you're willing to like suck
dick for it as a straight male right for
real
he's like hey i can let this one go just
for this yeah i only got to do it once
like you know what you you got to fix
all right i get it
yeah brian how was crack
[Laughter]
brian
come on the podcast and just explain how
it feels to hit a crack pipe
i really want i really want we need to
know what does that even mean
i think he tried to get a little you
know what's he doing in there i don't
know hey he might be shout out to brian
brian knows what it's like to smoke crap
hey
you never smoke crack cook hell no
you wouldn't try it if you knew you
wouldn't get addicted
i would try it if i knew i wouldn't get
addicted yeah if i knew i wouldn't get
it but i know my i have an addictive
personality so
that's why i don't do drugs i'm proud of
you i just smoke weed i need troops yeah
that's dope you feel me use it stay to
the earth yeah yeah i've never done
cocaine or done any pills or anything
that's dope i'ma just say this steve
jobs found out about or created apple
after he was doing lsd no lsd for sure i
mean there's a
mdma uh like they use it for therapy now
oh yeah that's dope um like people who
have ptsd from the army and [ __ ] just
pop one of them they do mdma therapy not
for real i know that me neither
learn something new on boulet care
podcast if you have ptsd out there start
doing some [ __ ] molly yeah exactly
being there turn
i feel like the bay area has a lot was a
lot of molly [ __ ] going on too man a lot
of different pills ecstasy it's the
whole history a lot man the bay area
historically is a place where you could
go be free that's why gentrification is
[ __ ] up yeah i heard about somebody
there's like some fair where there's a
bunch of like naked fools running around
um probably love fest or pride for sure
yeah i don't know i mean last time i
said yeah next week man there's gonna be
a lot of dude sucking dick on this
street
that's for sure that's pride bro well
then i am gonna make sure i'm not here
for that but it's hella crazy because
like if you're not homophobic or you
don't really trip off uh people that
don't or not don't have the same sexual
preference as you bro you will meet the
finest women at pride
like me and homies used to go i've been
i've been to pride in uh
in other cities before but san francisco
pride is different because you know san
francisco it's like our mardi gras so
it's like you got people coming from all
over the globe and it's like no there's
for sure some some ladies that pride if
you can if you can censor it you feel me
just tunnel vision tunnel vision yeah no
no i'm not homophobic
i heard that there was like they were
like they're they say they'd be [ __ ]
on the street i don't know about them
respectful you know live your life how
you want to live but you know street
[ __ ] yeah
i did see somebody at pride one time
having a threesome in the window and a
whole crowd of people was watching wow
oh yeah it was dope that was the year i
was in the catillion hey that was a dope
year 2012. we gotta run that one that's
what was great what was the uh what was
the dynamics of the threesome that you
thought was dope i'm just curious i mean
the fact that they was hanging out a
window and then it's like the dude was
getting bossy i'm saying then like as he
getting boss like you just think oh my
god they have a sex in the window window
and then another woman came and it was
like oh
it was like surprise factor it's like
when they it's like when they bring you
your entree at a place and then they
bring like a complimented appetizer
because they just like you know what
such a great customer
it's like when you order regular fries
and you get a curly fried thing exactly
it's like people thought it was just
gonna be blue like kevin stanley mano
too and if a filipino uh history or
heritage might we brought nico blitz
yeah mike we should have just had niko
do every interview this year honestly
you know
brian you want to come on the podcast
nah we got to do it for the filipinos
come on bro
adobo no but grab the mic come on
yeah come hang out with us we want to
know what it's like to smoke crack
we were talking
[Music]
i definitely could
anyway uh so what else besides this
record going crazy and viral what else
do you got coming man life is beautiful
i i didn't bring any but i got my own
juice company right now it's called o2
i'm saying no alcohol tac cbd caffeine
cane sugar and you know it's like a
booger we call it lime with a chain on
it cause it's sparkling
yeah it's a lot yeah just take it all in
and breathe it
just get some weed huh yeah
what's the juice it's uh basically it's
an alternative to soda so what i
struggle with soda exactly so you would
love this juice you know man it has two
grams of added sugar in there and it
tastes delicious uh we would have
something for you but man would you go
to soda um i just like coke um i used to
be a sprite dude fell along but then you
know i'm a big fan of uh kenan and kale
so
soda you know man or strawberry i like
strawberry too i just feel like there's
certain food to eat that like if you eat
it it
you can't eat it without a coke exactly
yeah i'm more like a brand person though
like you ever had a shasta soda yeah of
course yeah
like i feel like everyone hit like i'm
saying shasta just got put on for real
you get a shasta three liter for like a
dollar what
city in phoenix they got this brand
called fiesta soda
and it's three liters and they're 99
cents that's dopes
i'm not drinking that [ __ ] no more we
only drinking oh two juice something oh
two juices yeah make sure you go it
tastes like soda man basically it's like
it's more like a limeade that's
sparkling you know you know them tall
italian glasses just like that yummy but
it's just like no added sugar what made
you are you like trying to you know no i
got i got chronic eczema so you know
chronic eczema is like basically you got
my wife my wife has excellency
no you mean me we up here with it yeah
you can empathize yeah i'm saying but
like feel me with that you got to
basically just find things to help you
kind of kind of cope with dealing with
it your mind's just like diet is a huge
one diet exercise and until you feel me
everybody want to drink that like crazy
ass uh sugary ass [ __ ] you know
so you know alternative and we phasing
into health people being conscious about
health now so it's like i was like let
me step in this lane take advantage of
it help people they say you don't become
a billionaire so you give
the people something that can actually
impact the world
that's what i'm trying to do you know
become a billionaire where can they buy
the like is there a website
being my instagram page right now big o
two juice vig
zero two then juice yeah man we're gonna
take care of you only it's only located
in the bay right now we finna enterprise
and be everywhere you know just be
patient with us you know what i'm saying
be
patient uh
san francisco as like a city
i feel like
has always had like um
hometown legends like popping this is
you know what i'm saying like yeah right
rich right like you know obviously
there's been a lot of like
people who popped on the west coast or
in the in the city that
from san francisco but i feel like the
bigger artists are always from like
alejo or oakland or whatever but
recently 24 uh man going stupid shout
out to him listen
real quick burner too
yeah big burn obviously bernie is
somebody who's
a legend larry june is one of them but i
feel like
san francisco is like starting to really
finally get like a lot of momentum right
we're getting our stride yeah yeah i
know it's a lot of things i feel like
there's a lot of elements coming into
that i feel like you know it's a i
wouldn't say they didn't take it serious
but like it's a lot of things people
don't know about san francisco like they
just dropped something called swamp
stories there's a lot of politics going
on in san francisco before i feel like
and when people like my homie gunner
right here he with me when he was making
music it was like he was trying to
figure out how to stay alive while he
was making music now i feel like the
city got gentrified and is [ __ ] up but
at the same time and that being the case
you can you don't have to figure out oh
i'm trying to stay alive you could be
like all right i got a little breathing
room to really go get up and wiggle you
know i mean and now that our the rappers
and the artist is going up now it's time
to get the producers with us so we could
take that [ __ ] to the next level i heard
uh during the pandemic because everyone
left
that the rent went down though like so
it got like a little cheaper right yeah
it did
they allow people to get in there i'm
saying it ain't still how it should be
but you know it's a lot better way
better yeah because like uh
all the tech companies i think they
still you don't have to live there
anymore no yeah you could do remote and
now it's a blessing in disguise you know
i'm saying because i'm not gonna say we
didn't watch on in there but it's like i
feel like it brought up the value in
quote-unquote what the mainstream
america would like but for the people
who is like us the everyday people right
who enjoy life in the industry feeling
people of color and it's like you don't
want to live in a place where the night
life is hella dry filming you can't be
hella loud you know so it's like you
know you don't want to live there you
want to live where it's fun yeah have
the clubs like kind of bounce back in
the bay yet it's on a wave like hey
oakland right now i'm gonna say oakland
djs and everybody are going crazy like
the dj millions uh poppy for slim um uh
the dj shell hearts uh drew banger like
they are going like uh shout out to
oakley i mean they turning the night
life up and then right now san francisco
is kind of like getting into the wave
you know i mean and it's going stupid
right now because san francisco is the
only city there where they have the mask
mandate and all this city where they
don't really [ __ ] with black people like
that you know i'm saying hip hop oh yeah
i mean so well i know i wouldn't try to
go to a [ __ ] restaurant my boy wasn't
vaccinated yeah that's not the in
oakland you don't have to have the
vaccine i don't think so no you
literally just san francisco yeah
literally that's the only say san
francis that's only like nightclub
the mayor's smooth i [ __ ] with the mayor
but it's just like the nightclub scene
for like 10 years it's been on some like
i don't know i just seen it i went from
seeing it at like one of the heights
like lit every night you remember that
yeah bro and then it just feel me
decline but oakland lit though i [ __ ]
san jose too
oh my god lovely asian women at the club
asian women
let's play a round of applause for
asians
look at my girl she's like
filipino american heritage exactly yeah
how are you filming
oh yeah so saturday shout out to 24k
golden again shout out stretch they hold
camp i will be performing uh surprise
it's supposed to be a surprise
appearance but we finna turn up outside
lens i'm a thousand percent ready
gonna turn it out boulet kev is actually
gonna be on stage with me where's
outside lands san francisco his biggest
festival
it's gonna be huge but like kev will be
there if he's not there it's saturday
yeah yeah saturday i got a dj in 10
years see how you always do me bro
okay i'm trying to put you in the loop i
play your song though all right
appreciate the club all right listen i
need the video though i'll send you the
video yep yeah but you got to play it
every day for 137 days straight i don't
dj every day for i don't dj that way
even when you're at the house
i could do that all right cool give you
the little little stream big streams
just hit play that's how long do you got
to play before it's it's a calendar
oh dope is that even true
i don't know i don't know brian i don't
know
i can't take your credibility off
i know i know you know what what counts
as a spin on the radio
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anything else man that you got going on
you want to plug man uh mike ebbs hit
the big step man you know right now
we're just pushing back crazy yeah right
now that's the big movement right now
other than that go watch the last black
man in san francisco follow me on
instagram stunner man
you're an actor yeah for sure what year
was that like 20 20 18 2018 is there
anything you don't do no 2019 um i don't
do crack
nah are you like an active actor are you
like focused on [ __ ] right now right
what a musi music is the nucleus but
it's like if you give me a row i feel
like i could step into it so the movie
you were in prior what was the last
black man got mike absent tashina arnold
uh jonathan majors who just was the main
star lovecraft country gunner ghost
global whole bunch of you know it's
crazy that that song that show didn't
get renewed either [ __ ] the same yeah
they canceled it and it just got
nominated for all those emmys and it
didn't get renewed it's insane man it
was it was talking about too much stuff
you know you can't expose too much it's
a wild-ass show man man it's dope
you got any other movies coming out uh
we even talks with it nothing where we
just solidified it but you know just be
on the lookout because you know we're
gonna you know we i'm not gonna say
we're gonna we're gonna dmx this in in
the positive way that's why i pray after
every set i do but on top of that you
know how dmx busts the door open tupac
method man all those great individuals
50 cent ice cube yeah exactly well a lot
of inspirations that i just watched in
too deep that's hella crazy n2d was a
terrible movie i love that movie great
soundtrack though i love that movie
what's that makai pfeiffer and uh
yeah omar epps and ll cool j not a great
movie i love that movie
yeah yeah buddy it's all right
great soundtrack not for sure i want to
say
how to rob was on that soundtrack from
50 cent oh for real
yeah i think that makes sense because
they were doing a lot of legal activity
yeah disguised as a undercover cop it
was like who were like some of your
inspirations as like as like a rapper
like who you kind of like wanna you know
more so uh those uh rappers who could
act as well that's like any rapper you
can act i love that who's the best
rapper actor stunned man oh too beside
yourself but that's not everything okay
ask this question do you want me to go
against myself not [ __ ] cheating
but not uh somebody that's already
solidified i'll probably say one of the
biggest ones probably ice cube because
he wrote
movies and he was he was writing at a
high level for sure and then on top of
that he feminine made that smooth
transition he also kind of plays the
same guy in every movie that's true he
plays himself i like snoop too snoop go
crazy you think snoop's a good actor
yeah he's a great actor you ain't seen
him in bmf
i watched bones i was just about to say
that you ain't watch bones oh i did yeah
yeah he wasn't feeling it
keep it real were you feeling it i think
it was pretty good
all right let me think um gambino best
childish gambino you know what i'm
saying i think common's pretty good
comments
yeah
two pockets to go
matthew man that's what i said i said i
met the man i'm trying to think who's
the best actor rapper
i think it's probably common think so
yeah yeah common is like underrated
let's be honest
you got to throw some love to iced tea
too man yeah iced tea yep clean this tea
on svu been holding it down for like 20
seasons
new jack city bro
jack city bro
i'm trying to think ziki
no i he plays himself bro what are you
even talking about
smash the p dope
masterpiece not a good actor but he put
it together no he put it together great
boss great producer
not a great actor
common pock was a good actor
oh uh underrated most deaf right yeah
he's top doctor you've seen 16 blocks
yeah of course yeah
most def was fire yeah
no i would probably give it to queen
latifah oh yeah when you think about it
we are the greatest of all time not for
sure we don't even think of her as a
rapper like like people don't even know
she like she's so dope as an actress
like
people don't even remember she started
rapping yeah for going stupid
you it you and i t-y
actually said yeah yeah yeah yeah
i guess that would have to be william or
queen latifah
yeah yeah because we don't even i don't
even want to give give will that credit
cause he's uh he's so raw and he was a
was he like the first person to win uh
uh like what was it uh the the rap uh
grammy at the yeah the first rap didn't
show up yeah as a protest yeah that's
crazy bro like he him and jazzy jeff man
stupid shout out to will smith man hey
will smith well hey we need you to big
step will smith if you see this hit that
with us i'm sure he will not for sure he
probably just won't bring jada around
you that's cool yeah i'm saying i mean
i understand anyway
um hey so you got a lot of [ __ ] going on
man i appreciate you for pulling up it
was my pleasure yeah uh shout out to
will smith uh where can they find you
you shout out at your journal side of
man002 s-t-u-n-n-a-m-a-n-0-2
i'm saying go follow him please go
stream the song a thousand times is
there gonna be a remix with like uh like
like in the works oh yeah we got a hbk
remix pretty much done i am sue's on it
yep nice all right oh no
bro you remember when the bay used to do
like those big ass baby arenas
as i'm with that people been saying it's
outdated but did you get cool john on
the remix i mean they shot cool john i
got a gun now no i know it's i'm saying
that you you shout out them on the
record yeah for sure
i had to get him on here it's crazy
because i haven't heard cole john's name
a lot like since he just dropped he
dropped the project recently i love that
album of him and pillow the movie [ __ ]
yeah actually
yeah he just dropped a hard-ass album i
was slapping it he just dropped it
around my birthday like loki cool john
kind of gave like he was like the sauce
of the crew
man he had the merch he had the merch he
had all that he had all the sauce like
yeah he was and he's crazy because you
meet him he just calmed do yeah you know
what i'm talking about you know cool
john i mean he's just you never would
think but really
he got that aura about him positive
energy yeah eight shout out to hpk gang
man very stupid very uh that was like i
feel like one of the movements in the
bay that like
really cut through think of kayla you
know what's happening yeah and exactly
forgetting that kayla came from that
[ __ ] yep man i remember when kailani
dropped that or not that remix she did
we were sitting in a room and it was
like damn somebody was like i was just
in the studio while she recorded that
shout out to female hippie feel more
hippie that's a hell of a bay name film
of hippies
living legends amazing have you ever
come to san francisco look up female
hippie he'll give you the best weed you
ever had in your life
i promise i believe you i'm saying hey
you don't got to believe me but there it
is well listen man stunner man 02.
appreciate you pulling up man hey
authentic kid we're going to keep
winning whoa
there it is all right